Hello and welcome to today's episode of Rawkode
live.
Today we're gonna be taking a look at
behavior driven development test automation and to do
that I have my favorite friend and BDD
all around Guduk here in McNulty joining me.
Hello. Hi, David.
I'm glad to hear I'm your favorite friend.
Favorite friend and BDD consultant.
That was a Oh, okay. Strong
end.
Of course, I love spending time with you.
I learned so much especially around this space
which is one of those things I really
wish I was I wish I could do
it more often but again as a developer
advocate, I'm not really a product driven person.
And my role is probably just to hack
on stuff. So
tough.
Yeah. I feel I feel the same way
really. I do a lot of help teams
do this. But then I leave again.
Then
don't know about you. My career has been
a a sort of flip flop between working
on a product long term, doing lots of
different things. And you get bored of one,
don't you, and want to
do the other.
Yeah. I definitely like to experiment and I'm
always playing with new things. I was lately
like I'm a technology magpie.
So it's not often that I'm just working
on a product full time. In fact, I
haven't done in at least three maybe four
years now
but now that I'm starting to find a
lot more use cases for like, I've got
a couple of open source projects that I'm
trying to get to a point where they're
usable by other people and I'm starting to
think right.
They're not products that I'm selling but there's
still something that expose an API and expose
behaviors that I wanna be able to make
sure people understand
not just implicitly but through explicit documentation and
so far in a series we've
we've taken this get synced project which is
supposed to be a project that allows people
to build their own get up style operators
and controllers that monitor the status of a
get repository and then have certain behaviors act
on that and trying to expose that to
people is
what have we done now about three episodes
this is maybe number four.
This is three, I think. The three. Alright.
Okay. So we we did
First time we talked about what you're gonna
build.
Yep. They mapped naturally actually to these these
different steps of sort of BDD process. And
the first one, talked about what it was
you were gonna build, and we did some
example mapping as a way of having that
conversation.
Yeah.
Which is what you do in real life.
You talk to the you talk about what
you're gonna build.
Ideally,
you know, early on before it's all been
nailed down, you actually have as a group,
decide what you're gonna build.
The second session, we then
we had a bit a gap, which is
good because it's kind of what happens in
real life. It's not the ideal.
We had a gap, and then we had
to try and remember what the conversation was
and write it down.
So that's what we did last session. We
wrote down in this Gherkin syntax.
And, hopefully, both of those
steps are useful on their own, but then
this last step is we're gonna use that
written notes from our conversation
to drive our tests.
And it's been
weeks.
Well, we kept the
Months. The December break and, you know, we've
eased into I've definitely eased into January. I
haven't done too much streaming in the first
couple of weeks. I've just been, you know,
slowly but surely getting back into my groove
now.
So it has been a while.
And I think tends to encourage people to
do these things over a short time scale
but this time scale of like four to
six weeks
is probably realistic for a lot of people,
isn't it? So we might find we don't
quite remember what we talked about and we
have to rely on our notes.
Well, it's a good thing we have all
these scenarios now inside of a repository that
we can Exactly. To build together this test
test automation.
The fun thing is it's I also haven't
written any rust in a good month, maybe
longer now. So I'm hoping that all comes
flooding back to me. Don't think you've ever
written any rust. Is that right? Correct. Correct.
Cool. So we'll use this as a bidirectional
flow of information.
So we have a hello. Hello, Mohammed. Thanks
for joining us. Oh, hi, Mohammed.
We we
also have should point out this is something
you've kind of already written.
I don't know if the code you've got
covers the
scenarios we're gonna talk about.
But we can come in and kind of
pretend you haven't written it yet.
Of course. Yeah.
I did start this, but I think what
context is important, isn't it? What happened is
I started hacking away on the code internally
on a project
and it worked. And then I thought, well
actually I probably wanna use this on more
than one controllers. I'm gonna extract it to
a library. I extracted it to a library
really crudely
and then went I can't really expect other
people to use this if I don't tell
them how it works and I don't have
testing around it and the nature of the
library itself is all integration. It works directly
with lib kit like I'm not actually doing
anything
on my own logic, it's all just orchestrating
this on the library.
So BDD seems like a good way to
write these kind of integration tests and ensure
that it worked.
Don't suspect there are any unit tests
really for this application but maybe I'll surprise.
Yes. So the kind of tests
that naturally come from BDD scenarios are acceptance
tests.
So they're generally
the black box at some level. We can
talk a bit more about what level that
block operates at, but you're kind of probing
the system at some level and saying it
should do what I want in this situation.
You don't you don't really care how it's
working
beneath the level you're testing at.
In some domains, you would then also want
to write unit tests and integration tests and
contract tests.
But they're all kind of
in internal quality metrics almost, aren't they?
Whereas the if you're writing acceptance tests, you're
kind of validating
the external quality.
Does it do the thing
that it's required to do
at the level I'm testing it?
Which which are two different things. One is
one is
the acceptance test level, the external quality is
something that's on the
on the boundary of where the business engages
with technology in that both
parties care
about the external behavior,
both parties care that it does what it's
supposed to do, and both parties can sort
of evaluate whether it does what it's supposed
to do.
And the internal quality is the professional responsibility
of developers, isn't it? And it's and it's
it's the developers decide whether they write unit
tests, really.
You can have a manager bashing with a
code coverage chart, it doesn't mean they're any
good.
So all that internal stuff is kind of
away from the business, sort of internal to
the technology team.
Did we write any unit tests? Do we
need to?
Probably not in this case. Well,
let's see. Shall we?
We'll see. Yeah. Interesting to spot some tests
that don't
spot some worries
we have that aren't covered by the tests
we're about to write.
Yes. Definitely. Okay. Let me let's let's fill
it open. So here's our scenario
first. The the feature file.
Yes. We will. Yeah. Let's jump into the
feature files. So this is all on getthat.com/Rawkode/getsync.
I already have it cloned locally. Got some
code open, so we'll float that away and
we're gonna start with the first feature.
Which we did two episodes ago or last
episode even, sorry. So
I'm loving this not implemented annotations because well,
we haven't really hooked any of this up
yet. But I was really happy with the
way that we built these that with this
feature fail.
It really came together, I feel. And we
really destroyed what we wanted to happen even
with just like the first basic use case.
Yeah. So should we just Yeah. Go through
this like example by example to understand what
the application does?
Yeah. If if you that's. Yeah. Is that
what you would do? We should be recognizing
them. Right?
So that what did you write? Git git
sync expects to clone it. Oh, it's about
cloning when it starts up. I remember.
Yeah. We focused on the first feature was
like when I run getSync as a controller
Yeah. The first thing I have to do
is
well, it's gotta be configured in some way
and I think we've intentionally omitted all of
the config language because we hadn't really implemented
that in the code yet. But we said
that we would have a director that we
need to get a local copy of and
there are some conditions and some edge cases
where that may fail or we may have
to do some magic handling.
Yeah. And that config stuff.
Yes. It's really important when you're
writing tests or just with
BDD hat on, right? Writing tests and describing
something to a human is the same thing.
So it's really important when you're explaining things
or writing tests is to come up with
a simple example, and there's a there's a
sort of skill to that of picking things
apart.
So
I remember when we were talking last time,
we just started
mentioning these config concerns. We made a deliberate
decision. We're gonna remove that from the conversation.
So there's nothing in here explaining why it
goes into a particular folder on your disk,
for instance.
We would expect though
that when we build the configs,
if think about it in terms of bootstrapping
a project from the start,
we might then hard code everything. Hard code
all the config and get this working.
And then when we want to build the
thing where it reads a
I don't know. TOML file? What do Rust
people use? YAML?
No. It's it's TOML.
Yeah. That's when we'd write maybe a different
feature.
When the file looks like this, then it
should go into this folder. You know, all
those edge cases. And we talk it through.
So you you kinda wanna split these things
apart in a way that they're understandable to
people, but also with the sort of production
thinking.
You wanna split them apart in a way
where you could deliver them separately. You know,
we could we could build this thing we're
looking at right now
without worrying about config, just hard code stuff.
Mhmm. And kinda come back to the config
later.
Good. Because I think that's how the code
actually works as well.
Now,
I wanna make sure I understand this correctly.
Right? So when
so when it comes to implementing the test,
right, for each of these, do we just
pick the first example and we start adding
the step definitions for this to make it
work? Yeah. Why not? Okay.
I
mean, really it's the order that you want
to build it in.
Think it's I'm just a little confused because
I know that already some of this code
exists.
Yeah. It's tricky, isn't it? So sometimes you
want this if it's something where that you
understand how it's gonna work Yeah.
Sometimes you just work through it sequentially
or you pick the happy path first.
Sometimes if it's like
if you don't quite know how it's gonna
work, you might be able to pick one
of the sort of edge cases that's gonna
be easy to implement
first just to sort of get you going.
I must admit, I tend to just do
it top to bottom if I if I
feel like I know what's gonna happen because
it feels like a nice logical way of
progressing.
Yeah. Because I feel that when we did
when we wrote the scenarios that way as
well, we we tried to keep the simpler
things at the top. So it feels to
me that if we start to build it
as simpler test cases, we're starting to understand
how the library is actually gonna work. And
hopefully, of those steps become really reusable as
we get further down the more complex
stages.
Yeah. When when we were the order we
put them in the document is really for
a reader.
But that might naturally map to the order
we do them in.
What I meant about picking edge cases is
sometimes it's like, I've got no idea how
I'm gonna do the actual functionality, but if
I make myself implement the scenario
where
it throws an error message,
at least it will get me typing something,
and I'll have to name some objects. Objects
and
I'll have started thinking bit more and hopefully
by the time I finished that, I'd have
had more thoughts about the the core.
And we discussed them with this two this
so should we just pick the first example?
Yeah. I think what I wanna do first
is make sure so I didn't stall. I
hopefully have for whom I need. I just
wanna make sure I run cargo test. I
guess I should see all of the scenarios
listed as not implemented.
This would be
They should not appear.
They shouldn't appear. I'll
expect them to be filtered out.
Oh, okay. So we get the not implemented
yet sketch, not implemented yet sketch, not implemented
yet sketch, so forth.
I'm I'm good. I like that list. I
can see how far we are through as
we build out.
Okay. So let's talk about two different things.
That's not related to the tag not implemented.
That's telling you there's no matching step in
your
cucumber
file.
Okay.
What would normally happen is you'd run
is this inside a test runner or something
or make file or somewhere? So you'd you'd
run Cucumber with and filter out that tag
explicitly
if you didn't want this.
There's a difference between it means they're not
they're not implemented that you're seeing. It's saying
the test automation hasn't been implemented for that
step.
Whereas what our tag means is
this feature hasn't been implemented
in the code.
Right.
Does that make sense?
Kinda.
See a I can't remember what the flag
is. It's like tags equals
Well, I don't know if it's library specifically.
Maybe it's
The cucumber's
the cucumber CLIs tend to have very consistent
command line flags. Are you running QCamera at
the command line?
Yes. Through this Rust library. Yes. So I'm
using cargo's test tool, which then uses a
whole bunch of macros to generate Rust tests
and all this crazy weirdness. But I don't
think it's important right now is it? That's
we should we should be able to know
just to say, hey, okay. We haven't implemented
this scenario. So let's let's start
and see what happens.
Yeah.
Okay. So
let's pop open our test suite here.
So if people have never used Cucumber, what's
gonna happen is Cucumber is gonna run through
the steps in the Gherkin file
and for each
given when or then step, it's gonna try
and execute a line of code. So all
and that's all QCamper's doing, is it's matching
these steps to lines of code that that
David has to write.
So we have to tell it what to
do when it sees,
given I have no directory called.
Right. Let's see. Is it still legible if
I just do a split here?
Not quite is it? Alright.
I'll just copy this first scenario into my
my code I think so.
Okay.
And we'll put it here.
Hopefully we can keep that kind of and
display as we start. Now I
am not overly familiar with this library, I
have a
month ago I attempted to try and stitch
this together and then we talked about doing
this episode and I thought okay, let's let's
wait because we'll just do it together.
But we have this builder thing where I
can say I wanna handle a given step
and
the name I think just matches what we
have and say of
our scenario and then we just we just
tell it a function to run to execute
that step.
So Okay.
That means I can do given I have
no directory
called
get stink. I'll need to work out how
to parameterize
that.
Then we run some function and this function
I've already got.
Yeah. A couple of them here as examples
that I tried to do previously. So we
want to do nothing.
So I have no directory called get sync.
The implementation there
would be doing that. Yes. And it's
not because we changed the step. Right?
I have to actually enforce that that directory
does not exist.
Yeah. You could just check the directory doesn't
exist or you maybe would delete it. You
gotta think about, like, if your test crashed
mid run and things like that. So
different ways of handling it. What I'll give
you some options.
Option one is we check there isn't a
directory called git sync and we throw an
error if there is.
Okay. And the operator has to fix it.
Option two, we always create a new temp
folder and use that as the current working
directory
in our sort of setup.
So that kinda guarantees there's never gonna be
a Git sync folder.
So we're always making some, like,
unique ID prefix temp folder.
Or we do nothing.
We hope the next step crashes.
Okay. So
I do the
second one there that you mentioned. So when
this is the setup method for the world,
the world is just the
state that all of these scenarios run-in. One
of the things I do as part of
the setup is
create
a temporary directory.
Okay. So
this should be available to us and side
of our do nothing.
So we should have a clean environment.
We can access world.dir
if we want.
However, for the moment why don't we just
do
let's just do a print right and see
we're in just I just wanna see it
running although I think the printer actually swallowed
by the test runner.
I am a new world and directory
and we'll just tell it which directory this
is. The world that there.
Like so.
Okay. Yep. Let's do that.
Alright. Okay. That does something end of the
line twelve
eleven.
Sorry?
Do you need a semicolon at the end
of line 11, I think.
Oh, yeah. I need to fix that. Yeah.
Why
is this complaining?
So
okay. So I need to fix it. She's
one of these annoying rust things where I
have to wrangle it into something that can
actually be displayed.
So
does a path have display?
No.
So just to explain for the watchers.
What you're doing in your in your this
is called a step definition file.
What you do here is you define for
each line of text what code should be
executed. But you're not doing it in any
particular order.
You're just defining a kind of dictionary or
a glossary for Cucumber to use because the
same steps might happen time after time in
the Gherkin.
We have one one function here that's gonna
get executed.
And so the point of the world object,
each scenario, each example is independent. But when
you run each example,
you want it to have some sort of
shared state. So maybe we create something and
then a later step references it. The world
is where all that state lives.
So it's just somewhere for
stuff to live.
And it gets destroyed at the end of
each example and created new for the next
example. Or it should be. I haven't used
Cucumber Rust.
Okay. That should maybe work. Yeah. It seems
to have to work. Okay.
Let me try and explain this as best
as I can with my limited knowledge. So
we've hooked up the given. This is actually
not gonna match because of this. So we
need to look up how to do that.
And then tell them that the test function
is do nothing. We have or do nothing
here.
Now the way the print macro works is
that when I pass in this, it actually
looks for a trait
on the
the structure that
knows how to display the value, which this
does not have although never yeah, there we
go. So we can force it into debug
display with that which just means it doesn't
matter if it doesn't have display just print
out the bytes or whatever we have access
to. So I'm just trying to print it
out.
Now let's confirm my
thing here that this won't work. This won't
match.
So
we should just see all the skits. Excellent.
Not excellent but now we can work out
what we wanna do there. Did it skip
it? Hang on. Let me go. We have
because we don't have a match yet. That
should be alright.
No. Because we have this quote
called get sync and quotes and here I
use different quotes.
I think just escape them.
Could but I was gonna try and parameterize
it properly.
Let's let's see see if this works first.
Okay.
Okay. Okay.
Let's try.
I just forget how long things take in
compiled languages.
K.
Alright. So it's not matching.
Okay. It could be there's magic syntax here
that understands when that's in quotes. There's some
sort of variable
capture. Could be so So why don't I
take that out first?
Let's open that feature fail.
Yeah. Just put like, given I have no
directory.
Oh, yeah. There you go.
And then we'll work out the last bit.
So that should match exactly.
Why is there a hat at the start
of that?
I shouldn't have the Kevin.
I think that's why it didn't match last
time with the escape. Okay.
Why is there a what? Sorry?
I thought there was a
start of expression at this start, but maybe
it's just because I'm looking at it on
the wrong screen.
There we go.
Did you have a pair here?
No. There will be a way to turn
that on.
We're meaning that we'll we'll work it out.
I have run into problems with the rusting
swallowing them before. I know there's an environment
variable to disable it.
I'll grab it from another project and which
I'm pretty sure I have that in a
make fail. But right now, I don't think
it's important.
Okay. So
yeah. You you want to add a pattern
matching thing there, don't you? Yeah. So let's
see how we do that with this library.
There is There's a thing called cucumber expressions
but it might not support it.
Let's see. Language
but oh, it looks like it does rejects.
Well, have their own test written and this
of course. So
You can do given underscore rejects.
Okay.
So there is an everything is great for
wrapped in quotes. So yeah. I knew that
triggered some sort of capture. So how do
they implement that in
code? So capture runner.
We're sort of given.
Oh, this is like a completely different syntax.
There we go.
That is completely different.
I was hoping for just a dot given.
You look in the in the documentation, it
says use given underscore regex, and then you
can make it a regex, and you can
use a pattern.
Sorry. The other there's some then rejects and
things like that.
You can see how they do it.
Right. Where's their docs? Where's their docs? Here.
On this page, scroll down. See the then
underscore rejects. Stop.
Stop. Oh, yeah. Yeah. Yeah. Gotcha. Gotcha. Gotcha.
If do that, you'll able use a regex
as your pattern, then you capture the matches.
But I I imagine it'll be given rejects.
Okay.
Yes. We have given a sync, given rejects,
given rejects async.
I just want rejects.
Okay. Yeah. I don't know about async.
So now we can pass an a
rejects literal and I'm pretty sure I can
use anything I want here
because we need access to double quotes. So
let's do that.
I might be wrong about that. I'll come
back to Yeah,
I'm not sure anymore. We expect it to
be I have no
blah blah blah called
blah.
Yeah, it doesn't like that, does it? Okay.
Rust
rejects
literal.
I am a Google driven developer. Do not
judge me.
They're just we can just use the quotes
and
quote them.
Duck duck go. You always just get rubbish
or codey stuff.
Why is it not just returning the language
construct for this?
Never mind. Let's do it their way.
I'll come back to that and I'll escape
for now.
So this is now a captured group.
And what we're gonna see is
alphanumeric.
No. That's alphanumeric.
Yes. Spaces.
That's not that's spaces.
That's not space. Do you put a dollar
at the end for safety?
For safety.
And this changes our function definition now where
we actually need to pass in.
I know I could probably still pass it
and like, so I just need to
make sure and I should probably rename this.
This is
directory
does not
exist.
Mhmm.
And
we know Yeah. Sometimes name them actively, like
check directory doesn't exist or,
you know,
it doesn't matter.
K. And at least one I want us
to know what matches is.
They don't use an external function definition.
So Excuse
me.
Tell me the type.
There we go.
The list of strings. Yep.
See.
Not a single.
It's better to arguments phone one.
Look, your
string is finished there, is it? At least
the highlighter thinks your string is
So it takes it out. Itself,
and then it takes the name string, and
then it takes the test function.
There's something funny with the created string.
The highlighting seems to be indicating a problem.
Yeah. Okay. So
Oh, no. Still a problem. So we have
a mismatch types here as a vector string.
Okay. So
what we expect is is a back
string.
K. That keeps that happy.
Now we wanna get these quotes in.
Yeah.
Yeah. It's not happy with that. It's a
reject string. What how do you
No. I was
this is just a raw string literal. Hold
on. I'm gonna I looked up the wrong
thing. So it's raw string.
REST raw string literals. There we go. I'm
pretty sure you can use anything. Yeah. There
we go.
So
I got the syntax a little wrong.
So we do
pound and then I think it can be
anything I want and then I can end
up with that and now I should be
able to just put that in.
I'm making it really angry at the moment.
Hold on.
And then we end up with the same
way
with the hash on the end.
Doesn't look right. Right.
Okay. We got there.
It's happy. Right? It doesn't look right.
It's right. So what I'm gonna do here
is print
the capture and our configured environment. So we
are saying I'm in a new world and
directory
and don't
expect
this parameter which we should be able to
do as matches.
And this is a vector.
I
guess we can just print out the whole
vector
like so.
And now we need the rust format log
thingy
which I'm sure I've got in
this directory.
Rust FMT
log tests.
Just go to Google.
Rust show prints
and tests.
There's like a weird environment variable.
That's quite old. Let's send a new article.
Mhmm.
Rust log.
And no capture. Okay.
Let's hope for the best.
It may work.
Okay. Let's see.
So this is print output. Okay. So this
is using the ENV logger from my actual
source code which I'm not using in my
test cases.
So let's use that instead.
So it's it's also not matching the
step.
Oh.
Let's test my rejects then.
I'm sure I probably just messed that up.
So I have no directory
called
get sync. This is our string that we're
testing with
and it worked.
Let's make sure
I didn't change anything in the feature file.
There we go. Alright.
So in some languages,
this is slightly easier because your IDE will
know about Cucumber. I'm gonna let you click
from the step into the definition and
tell you when they're not matched.
Yeah. That step's passing. So
New York Cucumbers have this paradigm where as
long as there's no error during the execution,
even if there's no lines of code in
the step definition,
it passes.
Looks okay. So Well, we need to what
we should do is make it check there
isn't a folder called git sync.
Okay.
So instead of jotting.
First, check if directory exists.
I
don't remember how to code.
Yeah. I'm trying to share before
I even look at that. I'm pretty sure
it's gonna be really trivial and it's gonna
be like, we just want
path
equals
or from
whatever we want it from and then there's
You kinda want it to be the current
working directory, don't we?
Path new exists.
That was pretty close.
Okay. So
So can you assert that or something like
that? How do errors work in Rust?
We could do an assert. Yeah.
So if we do an assert equals where
we've got we don't wanna direct you to
exist.
We wanna use the path module.
We can just do from
I know they use new but it doesn't
really matter.
And what we're passing and is going to
be
the matches.
Give me some help here. That is the
zero
dot
exist.
Like so.
Run it.
Yeah. That's vector thing. I'm trying to remember.
It's better destructive path.
Than struct string.
Okay.
Rust vector
pop.
I don't wanna peak to show my head
to the pop.
V pop.
I really should just trust my instincts now
and again. But anyway.
And we want this to be
wanna see what we get because it's a
vector string. There we go.
No, we don't.
It depends if
the regex library passes you
the full phrase and the captured group as
well. It might be is it one or
two? Zero that you want? Alright. Let's get
this working then.
Do have a debugger?
I'm turning you to rust to be able
to whip out a debugger and use it
effectively, I'm afraid.
I mean, I'm turning you to even be
doing what I'm doing now but I'm gonna
keep sticking with it.
Oh, I actually have a check of exists
unit tests but
let's ignore that for now.
Yeah. I mean, you can mix on that.
I mean, you might delete some of the
unit tests
after.
It depends, though. Often, you'll have written more
unit tests than
were in the acceptance test. Like, you might
be able to think of more edge cases.
There might be a example
of the directory
being there but not writable, for instance,
in the acceptance tests.
And then you, the developer, might be able
to think of eight reasons why a thing
isn't writable.
And so you'd maybe do those
eight things at unit test level.
Alright. So I'm just gonna enable this end
logger.
Wonder if that would just work there.
There is a way to get print output
on a test and now I need it.
Rust
test println.
Yeah. No catcher's not working. Thanks.
It didn't work, did it?
Let's try one more time.
Although I don't see the output here. The
past.
I know but I didn't see the print
statement.
We're beyond prints now, aren't we?
Take the print out.
I've looked in the RS
lane 26.
So I'm using info here.
Okay. So it's already enabled in the project.
I think there's something where you can
Now you've already got harness false.
I know I should turn that on. Okay.
Call So take out the print take
out the print anyway. Let me change it
to debug. So
Oh, and I put that in the wrong
place.
So test live in our own module and
rust. So I need that here.
Push enables that macro. Okay. And then we
run this
and I want to enable debug logging.
It's coming back to me. It's a little
bit surely.
No. I don't see any
output there. Do you?
No. It's matching there.
Rust log debug.
I use debug.
Alright. Let's just get this start working. I
wanted to kinda know what
matches was.
Yeah.
Alright.
Let's just try and work through the error
message. So it's complaining that
I maybe popped isn't guaranteed to work at
compile time.
So I don't think that's a problem. Let's
do that first. That should satisfy it. Now
what I wanna see is that we have
some path
which we know to be a string
is
I don't know why it keeps messing with
my code.
Gonna come from matches which is a vector
or string
We want the first one
Mhmm. Which returns an option and I wanna
be able to unwrap it.
Now I should be able to use this
here.
Maybe it's because we didn't unwrap it.
Still not very happy about it.
Oh, you know I'm gonna have close the
records. What is excess return? You want another
closing bracket at the end.
No. It's not always tight.
So what is excess return? Oh, no. I'm
doing this wrong. From
path dot exists.
Close. There we go.
User error. Okay.
Now we're getting the size thing again.
Let's get playing. So what happens what happens
if Let's just unwrap this.
What happens if matches doesn't have any elements
in?
What does unwrap what's unwrap then?
Okay. So we could
well, it should add her, but we can
also do
Okay.
No. We just want yeah. Let's just let
the add her.
You type for me. I think if I
do it as a reference, should be
I
wish I was better at this.
I definitely have a string here.
The problem is is that path dot let's
see what path dot from expects.
So it supports multiple types. What about if
I just use new? That one's an OS
string as a reference. Okay. We can make
that work.
So
new. Is this what
I decided not to do earlier?
Yes.
And I'll pass in a ref.
Why are you complaining now?
Why is it error message that was at
the bottom?
And the one set as an OS string.
Why do you hit me so much?
I'll show a path buff and I'm I'm
winging it now.
So that's my string. There's my path buff.
Please just be happy for once.
I haven't used it. Okay.
From.
Oh, no. Why is that unhappy?
Oh, yeah. It's immutable.
Guess we can fix that.
So as we can do a colon.
Is it finally happy? It's
Wow.
That was
painful.
Mhmm.
Let's see if our assertion works.
It still works. Okay.
Do we trust it or do we wanna
create a directory and see it fail? Well,
so what I would do is just
change the string. So never trust the test
that is broken broken broken passing.
You wanna see it fail as well.
So can we give it a path that's
clearly got a file in?
Well, yeah. I'm assuming this is maybe a
root path as well and we're not actually
using that temp directory that we put in.
So let's fix that.
We can confirm that with a
we can confirm that. That's all I mean.
Yeah. Okay. Let's create a directory.
So
just
show me.
Okay. Creator. Thank you.
Alright. So
let's cause this to actually break.
So we want path
from
world doctor,
which is our temp directory joined
with our matches.
Oh, no. We have already got that here.
So pop that up.
I don't know the directory is terrible but
we'll call it path just now.
So that should create it
once it's happy
and port fs.
Rest.
And whatever.
I don't know where that goes there.
Oh yeah, I can't use the question mark
because
we don't return a result in this function.
Okay.
And now path is complaining. Let's go back
to path buff.
Okay. It seems alright.
No. This is complaining down here
because this has moved path. So Rust does
this thing where every time you pass something
along,
it moves it in memory so we can
just say pass a reference to it that
keeps that happy.
Why is world complaining here?
Why is world? Oh yeah. So
much fun.
Okay.
So now this creates a directory which is
a directory we expect to work. Let's copy
and paste this exact code for that path
and this test should fail.
Why is it going red? Just because I
hadn't finished.
Oh that's actually that's just complaining because I'm
not doing everything with the return type.
I miss a yellow squiggle not red. Now
let's run that again. It should
should fail. Right?
Yeah. You'd hope to.
Did
it? Yeah. True false. So
now we know this code
works. If we take out the create.
Yep.
Then we should be in a passing situation
every time.
Yep.
There we go.
We have implemented one
step in fifty two minutes.
Yeah.
I mean, of that was our fault.
It's worth mentioning. If you had other examples
that also said, given I have no direct
recalled something,
then that they'd all be passing as well.
So you can see all the other scenarios
have one saying, given I have a directory
called git sync
or a local claim. So as soon as
we implement each one of these, they
it it has knock on effects for the
other scenarios, the other examples as well. So
what's the second line? What can we go
back to the output again for a sec?
Yeah.
So now it's complaining when I sync the
blah blah blah blah blah repository.
Mhmm. It doesn't it doesn't know what to
do.
No. Because
we're so familiar with this one step that
we have spent so much time and love
and energy on.
Would you not then copy and paste that
to satisfy pretty much every other
well, it would just be this one, wouldn't
it?
They all look different to me. Was I
have a direction. Yeah. That's what I mean.
Would you just would I just copy and
paste this and implement that given step or
would you just continue with the one example?
You could do. I would
I tend to just get one example working
because I kind of think at the end
of the example, I'm gonna commit.
And I'd probably be filtering out the other
scenarios. Like,
if you look at the gherkin.
Yeah. The gherkin. Yeah.
In terms of like breaking big
chunks of work down to little chunks, I'd
quite like to get that first one so
it works.
Okay. Let's do it. So Without without any
error handling.
But, you know, in that happy in a
happy case where there's no path already,
get that working and then, you know, take
the rest of the day off.
Have a long lunch. Anyways.
So we got a given rejects.
Now we need a when rejects
where a rejects here
is gonna be something followed by I'm just
gonna call the same function for now.
Yeah. You've got it in common top online
18. Okay. So we use the same function
just now so the compiler is happy.
But I'm gonna modify the string
and it is I think the
something
repository
and
this can be
pretty much anything. I think we just need
a pretty wide capture here, don't we?
And then we end with this. I
mean we could do okay.
Allow Not not. We allow forward slashes.
We allow
colon.
I I normally do
not double
quotes
in square brackets.
Hat.
Carrot. Double
quote.
Escapes properly.
Well, seems alright.
Well, let's test it. So we've got tester.
It's
mostly escaping inside the Rust strings that I'm
concerned about.
Okay.
So we expect this to match. Gethub.com/Kieran/David.
It doesn't we also want it to match
a private one.
No. We we want it to match. I
sync the
Yeah. Okay.
It seems quite happy.
Right. Now we need a new function.
So this is
f n sync get.
I'm
just gonna copy.
Yep.
Function signature.
So the the world would be for it
to pass.
So in some places,
like, I don't know if we've done it
in this scenario, but you might in a
later step say, on that directory,
you know, it should be cloned into that
directory.
So we might in that first step that
we
where we check the folder exists, we might
want to stash into the world the name
of the folder.
Do you see what I mean?
So even a later step where
So it is in the world. You got
The
direct the temp directory is stashed in the
world? No. The the name of the directory
that we're cloning into.
Let's tackle it later if we need to.
Oh, okay. I understand.
The world is somewhere where you might want
to keep things for later.
As a general rule,
and, you know, very general, and you can
break it sometimes,
you wanna be storing values in there.
If you start storing
entities
or services in there, it gets messy.
Okay. So let's
do that. We do have a directory path
buff there.
Oh, no. We saw the temp in that.
So really what we want is like a
clone there. Just a string. Just a string.
Name of the folder.
We can defer this until we need it
later. Might make more sense.
Okay.
Calendar
by default will be
blank.
Yeah.
Oh, yeah. It's a string.
Bank. Okay.
And then
in the step we can populate it.
Okay. In the given step. I mean, we
could try.
So what we're seeing here is world dot
cloned or is now equal to our path.
Yeah.
Yeah. So it means in a later step
if we if the step doesn't have the
name of the directory in it, we've got
that context.
If that's that in that's that state that
just lives for the example.
Why is it not letting me make that
mutable?
Oh.
Oh, because when I pass it in here.
There we go.
Right.
So we should have access to that here.
So what we're saying is we actually want
to clone it to that location.
So
I'm just saying if we needed the string.
Well, I mean we would anyway. But
what's this step gonna do?
This is actually gonna use our library, isn't
it?
Yeah.
So we talked about this last time, but
let's recap.
We've if you look at the Gherkin again,
we've got we wrote five or six examples.
But we decided that if if they'd all
been tested at the library, we wouldn't need
to test them all through the CLI application.
You still believe that? Yeah. Yeah.
And we we even tagged them. Right? Can
you show that? Mhmm. We tagged
if those first two are tested through the
CLI,
in the other examples,
there's nothing that CLI is doing differently. It's
just handling whatever error the library throws.
So we're gonna for a first step, we're
gonna test everything through the library.
And then later, David can come and write
a different set of steps that
shells out to the CLI command instead,
instead of calling things directly in Rust,
which will be slightly slower as well.
Okay.
Yep.
Okay. So
that means that we need to get sync
where we can figure the repository,
which comes from our
let's
just
repo URL
is actually equal
to our matches.pop.unwrap.
And then
that now becomes repo URL. We also need
to specify the data clone it too. It's
repelling from the world. It's our clunder.
We need an interval. So this is some
of the configuration that we said we just
weren't gonna tackle.
Seconds.
Call it 30.
Username,
no authentication,
no private key and no passphrase.
So that gives us a get sync object
that's not doing anything
yet and I can't remember exactly how this
code works so let's take a look.
Once we have the structure,
we can just call clone repository
and it should not
return an error. So
that means we need to first assign it,
So we'll call this get synced
and then
what we want to assert is
that we do not get an error
we can actually just call the function to
do Yeah. So
in given you often have to check something
or do
Well, less often in given, actually.
In when steps, which is at the end,
you often have to check something and then
throw an error. Most of the time in
given and when steps, you're just issuing commands
and you're trusting the underlying thing to throw
errors
or the when won't pass.
And and this git sync object,
Dave,
we
there's probably some way of initializing that
ahead of the steps, isn't there?
Either attaching it to the world or
we do that later.
There'll be some hook. The the world life
cycle is is
to the example, so there's probably some way
of creating it in the world at the
start,
attaching it to the world
if we were gonna be using it in
lots of steps.
Okay.
Mhmm. Ugh. Why do you keep complaining at
me?
I'm just gonna do this to hack you
and then I'll come back and fix it
properly. So cool in world
world.
And then I'll use my cool in
Cool
Yeah.
Don't hate me.
Well, it doesn't implement clone.
Alright. That means I need to work this
out. Okay.
So the get sync library doesn't take a
reference to a directory. It expects it to
be mutable. I don't know why. That's probably
just a bad design decision.
So what I'm gonna do
Well, never has to it should never have
to modify on
that point.
The code that is in the step definitions
is very similar to the code that people
using in the library are gonna write.
Mhmm. So something that's benefit of
test first
is that,
you know, we'd have written these lines without
having implemented it yet if you're doing pure
TDD.
And that means that your
application API is gonna be very aligned with
the use cases. So
the line we're matching at the moment is
given us, you know, I sync the repository.
And the fact that came from a conversation
means that
that's something we're thinking about as one operation.
One, you know, one business action.
So
that should be one API I call that's
relatively simple
and maybe only takes the parameter,
you know,
largely only takes the parameter that's mentioned in
the text.
Yeah. That's a really frustrating thing with Rust
and you can't have partial structures without throwing
lots of optional types around.
Yeah. So you actually do need to specify
everything
here but I could definitely
Yeah. I'll need to work on that. I
think the design can be nicer. We shouldn't
always have to specify this stuff.
There is a default tree I could maybe
apply to it that would allow those values
to come out as none without being explicitly
specified.
So and you also try and match the
naming. So
what was the text of the step? I've
I've forgotten.
Scroll up a little bit, and we'll see
what the the git the gherkin text was.
When I sync the repository. So you want
the you ideally, you want the method to
be called sync
and the parameters to be called repository and
things like that just to make sure you're
really matching it to the you know, that
DDD thing of ubiquitous language. Mhmm.
Try and keep the objects named
the same way, that kind of thing. Yeah.
So the sync is what happens after the
clone when it enters the reconciliation loop. So
I think the language in the feature is
probably incorrect here rather than No. I think
it's correct.
When I sync it,
then the first thing the tool does is
it clones it.
So I I the user think of it
as a sync. I don't care about when
it's initially cloned. Right?
The way the the user facing API doesn't
ask the user to clone it first and
then sync. It's like, hey. You just start
syncing.
No. It does ask I think it does
ask it to oh, yeah. Maybe I could
fix that. Yeah.
No. I'm designing it from as if we
had hadn't written the code yet. Yeah.
The the kind of when we're in the
room when we're in the room with those
business guys that we were pretending in the
room with,
Every time they talked about this feature, they
said, when I sync the repository,
here's what should happen.
And they didn't talk about a clone step,
so we kinda captured that in the way
we wrote the scenario.
And therefore, we should try and capture that
in our API.
Okay.
If we can.
Let's run this test first.
Yeah. Don't rewrite it now. I'm just making
points for the viewers.
It's not a valid regular expression.
So the escaping thing you were worried about
has
no. Let's see why.
I think that
quote that double quote needs more.
Yeah. Maybe it doesn't need.
Yeah.
Either add one or remove one. I'm not
sure. Let's see.
Which version was that?
Depends on when it compiled and when I
saved it.
Well, look, it matched.
That's the important thing. There we go. Okay.
So Yep.
Worked.
Now I think I don't trust it. Yep.
Agreed. So let's how can I make that
function call fail? Let's take a look at
it.
It will fail if
Actually, we maybe don't need to. I mean,
we'll find out it's failed when we get
to the when step, won't we?
Well, we can copy that line of code
where we create the directory
and to this step and if clone
should fail.
So we can just do that. Confirm.
What have I got wrong?
Path is now
world dot cloned there.
So I don't think it'll clone into an
existing directory.
Oh, it did. Wonder because it's empty. It
doesn't care.
Can you look on your disc and see
what's going on?
I could have I knew where it was
calling to or not getting that output.
I mean I have rest log enabled.
Why is my debug statement not coming out
here?
Let's try
header. Right. That should probably always print and
then
make sure I have the right import.
Oops.
That should
really let that should print out the messages.
I'm assuming the best
BDD library is doing something on top of
that
to hide those messages.
And that's not really important to us right
now. So
let's just create a fake fail rust touch
fail.
Maybe we should press on
and go to the when step. And the
when step will fail if it's not cloning
properly.
And the point of the when step is
to check it's there.
Alright. Hold on.
You don't really need to add all this
extra debug.
The when step I just don't trust anything,
dude. And it's you keep going. I'm saying
it's for the viewers.
The when step is gonna check whether it
worked or not.
So all this extra stuff is just for
extra debug for future developers.
You know, you anything you add in your
given and when that checks it worked okay
It's just to make failures a bit less
mysterious next time around.
So if that failed touch works, then the
clone has to fail surely.
Have no idea what my code has done.
Okay, let's carry on and see what happens.
So the one step is
oh no. Then the repository is cloned and
the git sync directory.
Okay.
So
then reject.
Alright. Getting the hang of this.
The repository is cloned and
no. Do we need to specify this again?
Do we really use it from the world?
What would be the
right approach?
We have specified it again, so let's use
it. So we we we write the things
out
in a way that is clearest to a
reader.
The the what I was saying earlier is
if we'd written
and the repository is cloned into that directory,
we'd have been able to pull the the
string, get sync out of the world.
So so write it for a reader first.
Try not to try to make things clear
with what details are in which which line.
Mhmm. Drop out details if there's too much
stuff in there.
Okay. So
this returns world.
And this one is gonna be called
do we Check directory exists.
Check there is colon.
Oh. Yeah. That's that's stronger, isn't it?
That's our function.
Looks so.
So how do you check if
directories of client of a repo? I have
a method for this in my library.
Great.
Adds a slight point of failure, doesn't it?
The library could just lie to you.
Maybe I don't.
I can call it a public I thought
I had a test that opened the origin.
Oh, no. I do here. Yeah. So does
clone exist?
Yep.
Makes sense.
Hang on. What was that about not managed
by git sync?
So that's one of our other scenarios.
Maybe we shouldn't use that function.
So that's actually checks for the motes.
So I guess we just want to copy
this code and use it as a test
condition rather than using this function as a
No. Think let's call it.
Right. Okay. So
I think what we wanna do then is
store to get sync and our world,
which we do.
Actually update
it then and then just call that method.
Mhmm. So if we have our get sync
here, what we actually wanna say is
So that is there somewhere else we can
set it?
How do you mean?
Because now we're relying on running this step
before we run the latest step. There may
be a way of initializing git sync into
the world before every example,
depending what kind of hooks system
Cucumber Rust has.
This will work. Okay. But we'll work copy
and paste it for now. I think you're
right. Yeah. There there is probably some sort
of setup I can do around this.
Because you just later on don't want to
have a scenario where there's a different first
step
and then it checks the folder exists and
then it errors out because there's no git
sync in the world.
Okay. So I should be able to do
get sync.
Bet you that's not a public function.
Am I making it public for this? Just
for today?
Let's
see if it works. Right? And then We'll
refract to remove it.
Failed.
It's remote does not match get synced.
So
So maybe we're doing too much in that.
So let's just steal some of the code.
Let's just steal some of the code.
That actually it should be okay.
Now hang on. The the repo,
shouldn't that be
a URL?
Go back up.
Go go back to the step definition. What
are we calling it with?
In the check
go down a bit.
Does clone exist? But we're
We're calling on this.
Where's repo URL? Where's repo URL coming from?
That's wrong. It comes from the the match.
Oh, yeah. We don't have that here. That's
not in the step. So we what we
need what we need to have done is
in the previous step where we did the
clone, we need to have stashed the repo
URL into the world. I think we No.
We don't. Okay. So let's add.
And it gets a bit messy with having
all this state, which is why it's a
good idea to only have values in there.
You can imagine how messy that would get
if you had
I say anyhow, values. I'd just encourage you
to have the git sync service.
But don't have entities in there. Don't have
mutable objects in there.
You wanna be storing IDs of stuff that
you could then gonna retrieve again from the
relevant services.
So folder names,
repository URLs.
Missing
one twenty.
Okay.
So by default,
string from.
We've got a partial move.
Thanks.
Rest.
Let's
Now I need to make it mutable.
We put URL has moved here. I need
a clone of it.
It's horrible code but
I will fix it later when I understand
it more.
That's here as an as a mutable reference
to it.
Okay.
Or not probably mutable reference, but as an
owner reference and it's moved.
But I'm just gonna clone it for the
time being.
Because that's my answer to everything.
And then we have something similar here.
Partial move of world.
Okay. Just cool it. Whatever.
Rest can be a little infuriating at times,
but I still enjoy learning at the same
time.
It passed.
So we have a cloned repository.
Now
change the name of that
folder in the gherkin and run it again.
Okay.
Here?
Mhmm.
Don't know what happened there.
So that should fail.
Yeah.
Always always check it fails.
No.
Okay.
Why?
Well, because we're using Probably not using
We used the clone there from the previous
step.
Which is okay. It's just
you got something in two places kind of
thing. Yeah. Let's just match it So
I would do that.
If it look if you thought it was
redundant in the gherkin, you could just replace
it with the phrase like with the same
that directory.
And then it makes more sense that you're
getting it from the world. It's more of
an expectation.
Yeah. But that that's not what we have
noticed. I'm gonna do this.
Fail, fail, fail.
How many matches do we have in that
lane? Have I done have I done something
silly?
No.
Why
why does that work?
Why is it passing?
Oh, we're not asserting
the functions fine.
Assert equals. Good. Good work.
Yeah. So we expect that to say, yes,
this clone exists.
It's gonna fail.
So this is a good example why it's
good to do that little sanity check.
No. If we change it in future Now
when you fix it now when you fix
it, I'm gonna feel like it's actually testing
something.
And I'm gonna feel a lot more com
confident here. There we go. Great.
One scenario done. Five more to go. Let's
go. Well, we haven't got and the bootstrapping
completes.
Ah.
Yeah.
Does what does what would we actually check?
That's a tricky one, isn't it? Because it's
like it hands off to the next
stage of the process.
I don't think it means anything,
to be honest. Does it?
Maybe not.
So you could take it out.
You could I'm really having an empty set.
Yeah. I think why don't we make it
empty and then I think when we start
to add the reconciliation stuff later then maybe
we'll understand a bit more what it means
but right now I think there is a
handover and we should document it as such
even if I don't know what that means
yet.
Yes. So maybe just a comment in there.
So
and
or maybe there's no and maybe it's just
then
again
and the function would do nothing. We have
a do nothing, don't we?
I thought we did. I'll add it back.
Yeah.
Well, maybe it'd be good to document.
World.
Nothing.
Close that.
Button.
Oh, yeah. Because that was a regex. We
don't have a match and it do nothing.
So we need to take that out.
Should fix it.
Not implemented.
Oh, I've got the and and the master.
There we go.
So if we're doing TDD style, right, you'd
have
been writing
the code as you went.
So it would have taken longer,
but would have been sort of interleaved into
the time you took to write the code
and think through the problems.
Possibly, you'd have ended up with a slightly
cleaner API
or at least more use case focused,
but you still have had to solve all
those tricky problems
that you undoubtedly had to solve.
Uh-huh. I mean,
I think you're right as we were putting
that together, there were the ways in which
the code is being called that I don't
think I'm necessarily happy with. So I wanna
clean up the API definitely. But I'm happy
that we have one passing
scenario
and I see
those steps properly from the basis of most
of the other steps and the other scenarios
too. I'm hoping like there's not hopefully gonna
be too much other weird stuff.
In fact, yeah, looking at those other scenarios,
they're all get clones but with a different
origin name or a different remote like those
would be relatively easy to
to tweak for each step and reuse those
step definitions. So that's quite exciting.
I'm quite happy with that.
Right now, it's it's quite short in the
end of the the code. I think it's
a good
a good rule of thumb is that your
step definition shouldn't be too long.
Because if they are, it means that you
should probably write a method that does a
lot of stuff.
Because it's the kind of the code that
goes in those steps, it's the kind of
thing it's the kind of code that will
go in your CLI command wrappers.
When a web context, it's the kind of
code that will go in your controllers. It
could be like calling calling the real logic.
So if
if it's something you think of as one
step when you're talking to people, you should
make it, you know,
an action.
And if you're doing event sourcing or CQRS
type stuff,
it
should probably be a command,
sync the repository.
It shouldn't, you know, it shouldn't map onto
one thing being said along with us.
Yeah.
Well, I I think I need to work
out what happens after the bootstrapping completes, how
the reconciliation loop starts, how that handover happens.
I mean, in my head, I'm using
this is all built on something called actors.
I'm using an actress framework in Rust. So
really what I'm checking is that I
can start that actor. That's what bootstrapping complete
means. It's like we've now got a running
actor in the system.
So
I'll need to work on that.
I'm happy with that. Thank you for your
help there. That's really good. No problem. Alright.
Well, thank you again for joining me, sharing
all of your BDD knowledge. I'm really happy
we got that scenario completed. I hope it
was useful for other people. We've done the
whole journey together. We have done a long
journey together spread over many many weeks and
potentially months but
it's
it's good because every time we come back
to it, we do that recap for ourselves
which hopefully you know, is obviously useful for
people that are picking up too. So I
think I think we've shown the whole journey
from conversation
to you've now got a scenario that actually
runs.
You just make all you do is repeat
that now for all the other examples that
you've written, have more conversations,
and probably write some tests that run the
command line up.
But
it's just different given and whens that just
be doing slightly different things. Yeah. Well, I
will keep you updated anyway. Hopefully, I can
start contributing a bit more to this in
a regular cadence and actually making it a
bit more useful than just being the hacky
prototype that is. But
it has some very nice scenarios and it
has some pretty good testing coming up. So
again,
thank you for your time, Karen. I will
speak to you again soon and it's always
a pleasure. Have a nice day. Thanks, David.
Bye bye.